my name is Jenna Ortega and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
I'm very excited I love props
[Music]
is Jenna Ortega
is General Ortega related to Gina
Rodriguez unfortunately no people might
be asking if I'm related to Gina because
I play the younger version of her and
Jane the Virgin it was one of the first
jobs that I ever did and I also think
people always love when people see each
other in projects that are related and
they're actually related it's like a
nice fun fact I'm giving no one that
satisfaction with this answer is General
Ortega playing Wednesday Adams I
actually am I've never played someone
that has been portrayed before and
especially so flawlessly it's weird to
do something that people have already
created expectations and ideas of and
still try to do something different that
doesn't stray too far from the character
but also puts her in a different world
and atmosphere there's a lot of pressure
I think it's General Ortega a Libra yes
I am and that's about all I could tell
you I don't know much about horoscopes
but living in La I do know that I'm
Libra and I have been told you're such a
Libra and we're apparently really
indecisive and I am is Jenna Ortega
and Maddie friends I'm assuming they're
talking about the beautiful wonderful
baby angel face Maddie Ziegler and the
answer is yes she's one of my greatest
friends ever she was somebody that I
instantly clicked with we did a movie
called The Fallout a couple years back
and um I feel like Maddie and I are the
same person in different fonts she's
such a weirdo and I'm a weirdo and
like the uh used to perform autopsies on
little animals when I was younger like
little lizards that I found that were
dead in my backyard she's weirdo in the
sense that she breaks out into
characters or movements or make faces
always comes in at the perfect time her
comedic timing is so underappreciated
she she makes me laugh we have a good
time we're really weird together
Jenna Ortega
who does Jenna Ortega play in you I play
um Ellie and I'm obnoxious I'm in his
business way too much I'm definitely in
in La [ __ ] she's also very creative and
she's a bit of an artist and I see
directing in her future and she does as
well does Jenna Ortega do her own stunts
yes I love to I give stunt coordinators
such immense anxiety I will throw myself
on the floor off a wall I'll drive cars
at 90 to 100 miles per hour with stunt
breaks that I've never used before in my
life why is Jen Ortega in New Zealand
shooting that film X and I I was there
for maybe about three months I was only
in the North Island we shot in
Wellington I love that I I genuinely
would move there I love their
appreciation for their culture of the
Maori people and how they make conscious
effort to keep it alive and also some of
the sweetest people I've ever met
there's people that I met during that
that short shoot that I I still am in
contact with to this day does General
Ortega survive in x
the movie's been out long enough I get a
gunshot to the Head yeah I just had to
lay in the corner Dead with a prosthetic
on my face that gave me a cut and it was
funny because when I met Tim Burton for
my Wednesday audition I had just
finished doing that so I had stage blood
and glycerin sweat in my hair and a
massive cut on my face and had been up
for over 24 hours I got on the zoom and
he actually left it made me laugh I
thought it was I thought it was indeed
what does General Ortega look like now I
look like Michael Caine in a general
Ortega scramble suit
what is Jenna Ortega
what is general Ortega first movie it
was a movie called afterwards with
Marsha Gay Harden and she plays the
suicidal librarian who goes to Costa
Rica and she falls in love with a man
there who has
a daughter and I am that daughter it
also was my first time on a set so it's
learning what a gaffer is and what a DP
is and what this color tape they put on
the floor is supposed to mean oh you
want me to stand there you want me to do
whatever I was just kind of a sponge I
was just taking it all in for the first
time what is general Ortega
foreign
what is general Ortega new movie it
could either be a film I did a couple
months ago called finest kind with
actors Toby Wallace Ben Foster Tommy Lee
Jones or it could be the second
installment of the reboot of the screen
franchise Scream Six sixum is what I'm
calling it and that will be out in March
in theaters next year what is general
Ortega doing now
this interview
this is what I'm doing right now I just
finished a film in Atlanta called
Miller's girl and yeah now I'm just
promoting this this this Netflix show
it's called Wednesday
oh it's such a cruel world
how General Ortega
how is Jenna Ortega it's been a long
time since someone asked me that it's um
I just refer to myself as it truthfully
speaking I'm in a little bit of a better
place than I was in in the beginning of
the year and that's a that's a really
wonderful feeling and I've recently
worked on jobs that I had very memorable
experiences on so I'm I'm very fortunate
I'm I'm a very privileged girl how can I
meet Jenna Ortega I'm going to a
Comic-Con later this probably won't be
out before then but I walk a lot maybe
I'll be on the street how did Jenna
Ortega become an actress I begged my mom
for years I first wanted to start acting
when I was six years old my parents said
no way in hell one day my mom got me
this monologue book that she got from
Barnes and Nobles to shut me up like
here play and um I did a dramatic
monologue for her where I was
hysterically crying and she didn't know
where it was coming from or what I was
talking about and then I told her this
is from the monologue book that you got
me this is this is what you told me to
do she had me do it again and she put it
on her Facebook and put uh my little
drama queen whatever and I guess an old
friend of hers from high school was good
friends with a casting director so she
said okay just for a little bit and now
I'm 20 years old and I've been doing it
for over half of my life how old was
Jenna Ortega
and stuck in the middle I was 12 I want
to say and I finished it when I was 16.
it doesn't even feel like it was a part
of my lifetime I feel like I'm a
different person every day but
definitely every two years it's an
entire shift something that my friends
even acknowledged where my music tastes
a different style whatever how tall is
Jenna Ortega I'm six foot four I've got
my head in the clouds now I'm actually
I'm I'm five foot one or maybe a touch
less but I I think that's what I am
that's what I say is General Ortega
vegan I was vegan for a really long time
um but I stopped being vegan when I went
to Romania to shoot Wednesday actually
because the food is very different there
and I don't think that I was meeting my
nutrition requirements so I started
eating fish again so I'm currently
pescetarian can General Ortega sing
poorly I've I've sang for jobs before in
the past and and I'm happy to but I
would never want to make a career out of
it I would love to be a musical composer
I'd love to put out neo-composing albums
or things like that very ambient noise
can General Ortega Play The Cello
actually I learned to play the cello 4
Wednesday I started working on the cello
about two months before we started
shooting I probably couldn't play too
well now just because I've been away
from home so much uh working and it is
something that I want to continue to
pursue I have immense respect for
anybody who plays the cello I think it's
such a delightful instrument can General
Ortega dance if you want me to I'm not
against it I love a good time I love to
dance I love to go out and dance and do
it with friends and as someone I love
music I think there's so much to be
found in music and you learn a lot not
only about your own personal taste and
how far you're willing to to extend
yourself but then also about different
cultures and what is celebrated in other
places in the world and I think that
that's a really beautiful thing is
General Ortega Kenny Ortega's daughter
Kenny and I actually talked about this
we met at an event a couple of years ago
Kimmy Ortega is an incredibly successful
choreographer and director and is very
big in the musical scene I would love to
be related to him I think we're making
jokes about him possibly being a cousin
or an uncle but again I only met him
once so I feel a little weird calling a
stranger uncle
this is definitely one of my preferred
methods of interviews I think so thanks
for asking really
weird and sometimes basic questions
[Music]